adopter l'intrigue aura duré jusqu'à la
toute dernière minute le projet de loi 4
a finalement été adopté le serment roi
devient donc facultatif c'est donc
important de poser gestes que nous
posons aujourd'hui un geste
d'affirmation nationale on aura plus
jamais à faire ça
c'est vraiment un grand soulagement
trop peu trop tard pour le trio pékistes
qui aura du se contenter de passer la
session parlementaire à l'extérieur du
salon bleu
le Premier ministre n'a pas manqué de
souligner pendant ces traditionnelles
veut des fêtes j'espère qu'il nous
entend au bord de la porte
le secrétaire général m'a redonné la
médaille de serment au peuple québécois
que j'avais laissé à la sergent d'armes
rien pour décourager Paul Saint-Pierre
plat Mondon on est très heureux très
fier de
cette tenue debout
la hausse du coup de la vie a aussi été
au cœur des travaux parlementaires le
bouclier anti-inflation du gouvernement
se concrétise le projet de loi pour
limiter la hausse des tarifs
gouvernementaux a été adoptée
a formulé pour son bilan de fin de
session il s'est contenté de publier sur
les réseaux sociaux
c'est de mémoire là pour les plus
anciens c'est du jamais vu une façon de
faire vite critiquer par les parties
d'opposition qui jugent aussi que le
premier ministre n'en fait pas
suffisamment pour aider les Québécois
son travail à lui
c'est pas juste envoyer des chèques par
la poste puis fermer l'achat moi je
m'attendais à ce que François Legault
utilise chaque jour chaque minute de ces
deux semaines là pour combattre la crise
du coût de la vie il ne l'a pas fait en
santé éducation au service de garde et
justice nous n'avons pas au Québec les
services auxquels normalement nous
aurions droit
ces enjeux leur chef intérimaire promet
que l'automne difficile qu'ils ont vécu
et derrière eux cette session nous a
remis résolument sur l'objectif qui est
défendent les Québécoises des Québécois
c'est une année chargée qui s'achève une
année électorale marquée par la hausse
du coût de la vie et les défis
s'annoncent aussi grand en 2023
particulièrement d'un point de vue
économique les parties d'opposition
s'attend à ce que le gouvernement le
goût soit à la hauteur de ses promesses
ici qui me permettra au Canada Québec